promiscuous he has promoted I think
that's too far I think for women having
multiple sexual partners is really bad
for your mental health it messes up your
hormones biologically and also like even
if you're not technically sleeping with
all of them what kind of person are you
if you're just an object on millions of
people's screens and all that object is
is your boobs and bum they're not really
seeing you for who you are and if you
don't care about who you are enough to
put that out there and all you want to
put out there is your body and I think
that shows that maybe there's something
not quite right inside that maybe you
don't value in yourself so you only
value the exterior Part of Yourself